this is a production of Cornell
University
well it is my sad pleasure to talk on
the late Tom Taylor one of the
preeminent paleobotanist of our time and
to kind of celebrate Tom and Tom's
contributions to the discipline over
time those of you who have been in the
field for a little while like Fran will
know all of the history of this but
students coming in I think it's helpful
for students to see what people can do
but people can become and what kind of
contributions people can make and so I
can I don't have a better example for
any of us than Tom Taylor to emulate if
you can aspire to the success and
contributions of Tom Taylor and fail by
getting twenty percent of it done you
will be a roaring success in the
discipline so this is to Tom who died on
the April twenty-eighth at the age of 78
now is a bit of a background Tom
Taylor's Ohio boy we went to miami
university graduating in 1960 and then
he went on to the university of illinois
to work with Wilson Stewart at that time
the vast majority of paleo botany that
was being practiced was Cole ball
paleobotany the tropical wetlands of
primarily Pennsylvanian age and Wilson
Stewart was one of the leading ran one
of the leading labs in that area and
when Tom this is Tom this
his high school graduation picture so
you can see what he look like at the
time he then went after completing his
PhD he went on to Yale University and
worked with Ted dela Boreas who became
lifelong friend and confidant of Tom's
and immediately after finishing his
postdoc he was hired at the University
of Illinois at Chicago circle where he
arrived in 1965 as the assistant
professor he was promoted to full
professor before leaving in 1972 and he
took his first graduate students in 1967
when the graduate program opened up at
the University of illinois-chicago
circle then in 1972 he went to Ohio
University was there for two years and
then he went on to a high oh State
University to chair the department of
botany there and after 21 years there he
retired well he retired from Ohio State
University and he went he accepted a
endowed chair at the University of
Kansas where he went his chair of the
department and where he has been active
ever since he also had some significant
visiting professorships working with ted
della voice 1978 setting up the
international organization of paleo
botany conference that was at University
of Alberta in 1984 and then moving on to
munster where he became heavily involved
with riney chert and particularly the
Fogle by otis associated with that
here's Tom with his mother tom was more
than a paleobotanist he was a person and
he was a guy that a lot of us thought
very highly of here's there are two
kinds of slides here though the ones on
the black background that I've made up
in the last two or three days and then
there are these that are very artsy that
Ruth did for a program two or three
years ago so here she celebrates it his
mentor Wilson Stuart here's some early
fieldwork and in this will be a coal
mine in southern Illinois here's Wilson
Stewart here's Tom here's another one of
the same era here's Tom here's Don
eggert who Tom worked with it very
closely for many years and Dave dill
chirp now Tom's career is a fantastic
example of research productivity
research breath research innovation and
rigor high very high standards of
quality in his research he published 468
peer-reviewed papers this is a goal
didn't it on your way Kelly yeah and in
peer-reviewed journals and edited
volumes he published three editions of
his very famous and popular paleobotany
textbook here's the last edition of that
he published the first paleo mycology
textbook which just came out the last
few months here and to follow the
progression of Tom's research we see
that he began working on morphology in
anatomy of Kobol plants as a graduate
student he worked he then was very
interested in little things he became
very enamored of and worked on pollen
and spores which brought him to electron
microscopy he brought the first scanning
electron microscope in the city of
Chicago into the University of Illinois
and we had it in the lab there when
medical schools had to come and use the
equipment so and he developed scanning
electron microscopy techniques that are
used paleobotany today he also used
transmission electron microscopy and
some of his students were trained in
that realm later on he became interested
in fossil fungi which we knew very
little about and which was very
reasonable because paleobotanist for
vascular plant people and fungi you find
in anatomical sections preparations and
paleobotanist always want to have the
nicest anatomy and of course the fungi
you find in the crappiest anatomy
because they've been working on it so
although they're fungi were extremely
abundant we didn't look at him because
we didn't know what to look for tell Tom
got into it he that brought him into
organismal interactions through time and
his last major conquest with antarctic
paleo botany working on permian-triassic
and jurassic by otis some anatomically
preserved from the church and some
compression fossils here's some early in
the field shots collecting coal balls in
the Sahara number six mine southern
Illinois here's a shovel here it's about
that that's about the size of a
three-story house and here we are like
little ants the shovel is actually about
a hundred yards beyond where we are
collecting there and we collected them
in the pits Tom worked on the genus [ __ ]
testa the medicines for his doctoral
dissertation and after collecting these
things and bagging them up we would fill
up u-haul trucks with them and then we'd
be extremely tired at the end of the day
we just kill ourselves doing that stuff
and so there were
I think 6,000 cold balls that were cut
catalog in the plants identified and
cross-referenced University of
illinois-chicago circle tom was a 8th
outstanding mentor students so in
addition to scholarship we have
mentorship East and he took his first
master students in 1967 and there's a
list of the people who had master's
degrees with him he turned out doctoral
students from 1975 right on up to 2015
and you see a large number of names of
people here you know on people who have
gone on to be productive scholars in the
field here are some pictures of Ruth put
together for his 75th birthday
celebration of the former students I'm
not going to be able to go through all
of these because of the time but this is
going to go up on the web so anybody
who's interested can actually read all
the names they will point out a few
these are early graduate students Jim
Mickle there's Ruth and there's ed
here's Mike Malay down here and there's
of course Tom working hard in the field
this his teaching went on all the time
and this is this is a field trip to
arkansas working on mississippi and
stuff with done egerton in his
competitor with his tongue out here and
sheila brat here and here he is teaching
in the field
here are more students and from his Ohio
State days with Kathleen pig Charlie
good Sarah Stubblefield who did a lot of
the early mycology work with Tom as Ruth
again here is Mike chin who was
tragically killed in an air crash coming
back from the meetings it was the plane
that crashed in Detroit in the city more
students chucked all in with Ruth
there's patty and won't go into won't
name them all because of time I will
point out one one person here though
here's Michael cream so the only picture
I have of any of his German connections
so there's Michael who he's worked with
very extensively in the last few years
in the mentorship continued on to post
Doc's Tom had a few postdocs during his
time and I'm not going to talk about any
of them individually but I will point
out that the postdocs extend from 1975
to 2015 from around the world a large
number very productive scholars today
are on this list he also had very wide
collaboration so in addition to
scholarship and mentorship collaboration
with colleagues is something that he did
very well and these are a list of not
all of his collaborators these are the
visiting scientists that he hosted in
his lab over the years and this is
include our colleagues from around the
world and many very prominent names as
well
now along the way he built a lot of
really strong friendships cadell of
aureus has been a very close friend of
his over the years this is mike bolter
from England and very Thomas from Wales
and here is this is Bill challinor from
England in the early 1980s Tom began to
work with Argentine paleobotanist this
is sergio arc and gel ski papa the
patriarch of paleobotany in argentina
and he began working with Sergio and his
students which has brought together a
lifelong collaboration and little kids
like this came into it along the way
just Tom on a collecting trip back of a
truck in Patagonia
argentinian snow how to have a good time
so here's revenge cuneo who was here
last week and here's nacho at Scapa who
spent a year here a couple years ago six
months six months here a couple years
ago yeah this is uh an asado that we had
when I was out in the field with him
four or five years ago here's an early
one from 1985 there is Papa there's Tom
and there's ed I don't know the other
people in that photo you do I'm sure you
would okay and so tom went back and
forth between first ohio state and then
from Kansas to Argentina here he isn't
the Petrified Forest he actually started
unworked from this when he put ruth
stocky on her master's and doctoral
dissertation on cones from the Petrified
Forest and I don't have time to tell you
about her never being there because she
got deported from Argentina but and then
there was the German collaborations and
I'm afraid I don't have pictures of the
German collaborators because I'm in the
midst of moving from Ohio to Oregon and
everything is packed and so in the two
or three days I had to put this together
i was unable to get pictures but he went
over there first on an alexander von
humboldt senior research award for 1994
49 and again in 1996 actually and he
worked on riney chert that Winifred rimi
had been working on and he worked
actually some with ramy but more with
hot skirt and his technician who
and collaborate hog and Haas and most
recently with Michael cranks who he's
worked with very extensively recently in
this a co-author on the fossil fungi
book so that's been an extremely
important collaboration both for paleo
mycology and for biological interactions
through time and finally the last thing
that tom is done which has made a really
major impact is antarctic paleo botany
of the permian-triassic and more
recently up into the Jurassic with this
really good stuff that starting to come
out of there now so here's Tom dressed
for the the helo now to put this in
perspective the James Morton shop or old
Jim shop who was one of our paleo
botanical patriarchs in 1960s was at the
US Geological Survey coal geology lab in
ordine Hall on the ohio state university
campus across the campus from tom when
he was there and jim was working on
antarctic fossils in the 60s and into
the 70s and when he died in the late 70s
his mom picked up the material looked it
over and realized that there was just a
huge amount of work that to be done with
it shaf had just barely scratched the
surface so he picked up the mantle from
shop at that time and extended it into
permian-triassic and Jurassic church and
compression floors that we have seen so
much of over the last few years but Tom
and his students and his post Doc's in
his collaborators so here's some
pictures from Antarctica
it's a great picture of Tom looking
content here are some of the people who
worked with John Isabel and Ruben cuneo
oops this will be Isabel and this will
be Ruben and somewhat younger date this
is the first Antarctic trip that Tom
took where you went with Ed and Ruth
gross times easy to pick out here this
one's Ruth and they were not only
collecting but they were doing things
like who they're building an igloo
because when you went down there at that
time you had to do survival training and
so you had to build yourself a shelter
and stay in it overnight and since well
overnight even though there's no dark
light all the time here they are penguin
rookery the Penguins hairs Ruth working
from a snowmobile or a skidoo and Ed
there and then here we are packing up
fossils I didn't go with him on the
first trip but I went with him a couple
of times later and more shots of life
when you're camping out in Antarctica
and collecting and this is the source of
the material it gets collected it gets
boxed up in crates gets put on the ship
shipped back and arrived several months
after you get back the one of the
biggest camps they have is it Beardmore
glacier and here's the 1976 or 1986 crew
at Beardmore glacier here are some of my
favorite pictures from there I always
thought that this was Tom being serious
about having people collect
and and here is the his certificate of
completing the snow craft in survival
school in that 1985 and you can see how
much he's enjoying himself in that
environment there
another area where tom was extremely
influential isn't building our
discipline tom has been an extremely
important builder of paleo botany at the
national and international levels he was
very important in building the
international organization to paleo
botany where he was president at one
time in the 1984 he went to the
University of Alberta for six months and
he and Ruth organized the second
international organization of paleo
botany conference University of Alberta
and has spectacular field trips there
these are shots of a paleo seen locality
and here's how they made the fossils
available to people they ran over there
with the bulldozer and cut shelves back
so that people just go ahead and collect
the fossils and spectacular collecting
they also had a champagne and watermelon
at the end of the collecting trip Tom
always did everything with class they
went to the lots of places in the
Canadian Rockies while they were there
here he is with Ted and here are some
Japanese graduate students on the
athabasca glacier where there pulls the
water and it would stick their hand down
in the water and at time them to see who
is a toughest and could keep it in there
the longest Tom had a lot of family in
terms of scholastic family and friends a
lot of people with whom he is very close
and influenced extensively he worked
very closely with with Don eggert for
many years they were together at the
University of Illinois at Chicago circle
in the late 60s and early 70s and at
that time it was probably the most
active paleo botany lab in the world
they had a dozen graduate
students going and here are some of the
of this crew including here's Ted that's
Mike the other side that's guy I don't
know he's what he washed out there's
very careful Marian Wilson here's Ruth
and Ed that I'm not sure that could be
cookie trivet there's some marine thank
you every buried Herman yeah I was at a
meeting around nineteen seventy maybe
something like that I was looking for a
picture it was old enough for Bill not
to have white hair but I couldn't find
one so here's a fortunately for we were
able to have a celebration for Tom when
he turned 75 and in 2012 and we had a
celebration of that at the Paleo
botanical banquet at the Botanical
Society meetings and then later in in
September that year at the OPC we had a
symposium dedicated to him and from that
came a special issue for the
international journal plant science we
had I forgotten 2425 papers by a almost
50 authors all of whom had been very
closely associated with Tom as students
former students students of former
students postdocs former postdocs close
collaborators and people he worked with
in building the international
organization of pedo botany so we were
delighted to be able to honor him with
that in the thomas & Taylor Diamond
Jubilee special issue the intern
journal Applied Sciences that came out
2013 now the last thing I want to talk
about is Tom as a poet you don't think
of Tom as a poet but his students do and
it brings out some of Tom in a more
personal sense the types of things which
have made in dear his students to him
and him to his students he would write
poems for his students and leave them on
their desk now fortunately I cleared out
of the lab before he discovered he could
do that and he often did that with when
somebody had done something that was a
bit embarrassing is that or somebody did
something that was really outstanding
this is a Charlie good at the time I'll
read the beginning of this there once
was an employee named good who worked
with fossils as best he could his
talents and drive were better than most
he even was known to occasionally boast
that's a little digging in there and
then I'll to skip down the bottom for
morale I have none to relate to this
chap but there he but were he now hear
me through Thunder would clap and
probably an echo would be whispered for
sure your dear friend and colleague in
occasional butcher Charlie had screwed
something up and you left the note on
his desk i am not going to read all
these here's one that was that he wrote
for ed when she was his student where
she had I think done a misidentification
which he brought to her attention with
this poem
ah here's one for Lisa Boucher here's
one for Jeff Osborne and here's what
real long one for Murray kerman and
since these are going to go up i'm not
going to bother to i'm not going to read
them because i don't have the time but
over the years ruth was complaining that
he never wrote a poem for her and so at
the roof growth that we had when she
retired University of mérida that was
held last year he wrote a poem for and
he read it i think i'm going to i will
play that for you there once was a last
name started all my poems begin there
once was there once was a last name
stocky who's climbed to the top was
always rocky she labored away night and
day searching for perfection some did
say for a reason we distill far from
clear this last sake was sometimes heard
to cheer isle of pines I'll akerians and
even you I'm a gymnosperm down through
and through give me stomata with sunken
guards useful climate secrets that are
known to castel a Place in the Sun were
all will know I was the first to
describe him and not just for show her a
search was silent and easy to share she
got funded to travel here and there do
comparative studies with much to say
junos
rooms are great but now pass their
heyday are you for the years to come
maybe's teach students that are far too
dumb boy diploid source and stores ferns
might be fun but the researchers are
bores I now she had traveled some
distance away where the winters are cold
and the snow is all played to a land
where all colours continue to stall
there's also the home of the edmonton
mall now entered a wise man named
Stewart who said Ruthie might be air you
won't need a sweat this isn't a sight I
know very well where the summers are
great and the winners are held the four
floor of their screams visit our grade
will show you stuff that will make even
watch well range many hold secrets that
some will scorn that we were around here
before even you were born flowers abound
they're all over the place with perianth
parts in your face son Drew and waters
others dry land Princeton's our names so
give us a hand will set you off to
publish more stuff with your students
and colleagues some enough up just think
about the data we humbly whole new
hypotheses for perio botany that can be
easily so
and so she went to Princeton that Yale
collecting megatons and rock and even
some shale trapping the stuff and
looking for plants so even with fungi in
their pants the bio not Waller your
curiosity stronger I look this stuff she
sent you all the eocene is great it's
even a ball and then one day a new
friend would say there's a place that I
call the Appian Way petrified stuff all
over the place nodules in rocks some
even in place and so it went from this
site to papers and talks more research
to do is this getting too long in
reading this poem to a meet one night
whose eyes roll up and then on the side
stop it term I can take no more your
knowledge will think you're a terrible
more after crying out loud the shameless
poet did say I've given your Ruth your
special day a verse for her it is long
overdue if you don't like the rhymes
here then screw all
so with that in mind when Tom became
really ill in the last month proof wrote
a poem for him and I'll try not to screw
it up too badly a poem for Tom Taylor my
wrist Aki there once was a botanist
named Taylor who said that I talked like
a sailor mentor and friend no horses
rear and a Prince of a fellow Tom Taylor
his microscopy type was scanning flames
of palin ology then he was Fanning
pollen and spores no study for boars
carboniferous cold balls in planning his
partner in crime was named Donald a guy
who with no need to be coddled they blew
up the truck with a little bad luck
falling rocks was the story they modeled
a fern they named to Delia with fern
characteristics so curia named for dello
various the name was just glorious but
Norwood heeya oh my odious Tom perfected
the method of peeling ground [ __ ] testa
with verb and with feeling carboniferous
seeds fulfilled all his needs but in
time needed work more appealing left
Chicago for Athens Ohio an additional
notch on his bio start of interest in
fungi we all know this fun guy was a
scientist there for tomorrow callum
it's-- radstock iya and seed ferns
Bowman ID sakky pollen and we learned he
said that ontogeny recapitulates
phylogeny toward reproductive biology he
turned he moved on to columbus ohio to
be chairman department of bio the
dandelion bloomed an insurrection loomed
but he triumphed in time meal mile his
students the line should be towing
darkroom whining on time spent is
growing help with foot fatigue called
those these workers bush league
rubber matting the solution now showing
his wisdom for his students legendary in
this lab no need to stall or ever Terry
get your pubs drafted or else you'll get
shafted good job good now good jobs are
what's customary in my lab you'll get a
PhD in moving its kool balls from the
strata we're removing publish or perish
the mantra or weed cherries it's
hypothesis we should be proving all is
students at the Uni so productive
studied gymnosperms horsetails and firms
reproductive it's time for cathartic
will collect the Antarctic glossopteris
sure sounds deductive Beardmore glacier
laboratory students added to the story
fossil plant explanatory working on
their oratory came cambium and fossil
phloem some of them deserved a poem all
of their work is laudatory added greatly
to his glory many reconstructions of
whole plants even gave us time to work
on grants ferns and fungi from Triassic
developmental studies classic
paleobotany ramps from fossil plants
from the chert known as rainy with fungi
included so tiny studied with Hagen Haas
in others with class with life cycles
that formally stymie the Permian studies
of tree rings conifers cuticles and like
things lichens and a side the studies
were classy bacteria with Mikkel creams
pennsylvanian leaf epiphyte fungi were
described by this famous once Buckeye
cones of the cycad spores found in dyads
were papers with his old alumni his
paleo books have been well-received even
better than we all believed biology and
evolution was his great contribution
each particularly well achieved what
will be his future goal
will he study petioles will he macerate
some coals will he have new founded
roles must stay away from all [ __ ]
we who have benefited from his
instruction succumbed to paleo botanical
seduction learned the powers of chanical
deduction practice whole plant
reconstruction try to emanate his
production so there is Ruth
recapitulating Tom's career and his
effect on his students and colleagues
here are a list of awards and honors I
will point out that he his awards
include distinguished scholar
distinguished teaching awards here's his
national academy of science selecting
amongst the others and so as a an
example of what one can be and what we
all wish that we were and what students
still can be so long tom we miss you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu